oh my god it's in san francisco
nice okay we've got a plan oh this is
pve
wait all right there's way too much goo
oh
okay reacts react says got some tech
that was so
sick i would not want to be anywhere
near that
hey everyone persia here and today i'm
joined by kurt
and we are going to be reacting to
rainbow six extraction
the brand new trailer just released at
ubisoft forward
during e3 so we want to go ahead and
check it out but later we're also gonna
be breaking it down so make sure you
stay tuned for that
kurt you ready i am so excited for this
persia let's go
already until a piece of it
fell oh wait hold up
being that close to a meteor is never a
good thing i'm just going to throw it
out there
there's finca at least we have that
confirmed all right and
and definitely and ash okay
it could be contained react so oh my god
it's in san francisco
it's our hometown baby that's where i'm
at
wait huban is m.i.a we definitely gotta
get her
so okay so there's react those are
ella's
i get to recognize the sticky bombs
ella's my girl that's my mane right
there
so i already know i love ella so much
oh my god i hope we do find her first
because
those sounds i would not want to be
anywhere near that
[Laughter]
nice okay we've got a plan we're in
there
so that's three we have three people
going and opposed to the usual
four or five wait she said they're
already out of the nests
oh this is pve yeah and they
are creepy looking and shooting spikes
so persia and i are gonna be i'm calling
ella by the way persia when this all
goes down
wait what hold up that was my man we
went through this
i don't know lion is looking pretty sick
right now
there's that air jab baby
yeah we're gonna do watch out
for explodey spikes that's pretty sweet
all those spikes
are definitely doing some damage so now
we'll equally have to be
tactical about how we also invite avoid
killing these things
and we still got that element of looking
for an objective here
with the drones but it looks like his
abilities change though we don't have
the drone anymore but instead just a
location device all right well we found
wait all right there's way too much goo
they're swimming around in it
i i don't like that this is dangerous
so they're different though these are
all different like
gooey sentient dudes we're dealing with
here
oh okay react reacts has got some tech
so this whole react thing is gonna be
changing our abilities
in the equipment and gear we use all
right this is the big boss this is the
head honcho
everyone's listening to him so those are
different dudes that we saw earlier that
are actually a projectile not this guy
again
so this is where this is where
coordination and cooperation is
important
that was so sick oh here we go we're two
for two on the air job
dude nomad and a grenade oh the wombo
combos and
friendly fire okay i'm i'm about some
friendly
fire okay there's gonna be a lot of
cooperation with us to take these
gooey dudes down did we make it
oh of course we made it kurt of course
we made it silly me
silly me look at who we got here wow
look at the whole team
masks off
the fireworks
so we need to get in as much as we need
to get out and it's all coming in
september 16th long ways away
now that we've had a chance to check out
the trailer for the very first time
i think it's time for us to go back and
look at it slower and
closer so we can get all of the fine
details hashed out
courtesy of ubisoft so let's check it
out habana specifically says
a piece of the heavens fell so this is
from
space this is from the sky what does
this even mean it's definitely nothing
we've seen here on earth before
until a piece of it fell
so this is where we actually get to see
some familiar
faces and of course we've already seen
habana but in the corner here this is
where we see finca for the first time
and then ash kind of scurries
right in the front of us but there's
also another thing that's really obvious
about this clip
is that donut bagel donut circular
doughy thing in the background
um that was in persia help me out it's
this is new mexico yes this is true or
consequences new mexico
the outbreak event which makes a ton of
sense seeing
finca here because obviously when you
think finka you're also gonna think lion
and you're also gonna think
operation chimera which i think is going
to be
a huge thing in extraction
she's pretty much the one you want on
your team when other whenever anything
crazy is going down because she can
power you up
that adrenaline boost
we thought it could be contained right
in
to our home city of san francisco
and tenderloin look at this
behemoth coming out of the building
which we know now is called the carapace
this thing is massive so we did too
stop right here we already know
havana got captured then they shall
pulse
he is stressed i am my heart is being
ripped to shreds because we know
pulse and hibana share a very special
bond
yo it's gonna be cool we're gonna get in
there and extract her
because this is rainbow six extraction
exactly so on the side it says analysis
containment team which is obviously the
last three letters
of react so response excitement
analysis containment team so something
about this still we see in the corner of
the map
where it kind of shows where a lot of
things are popping off ground zero
is still new mexico which we also know
from before
as well yes so lion being a part of this
is huge
extraction team now
so right here in this moment that's mira
dishing out some
familiar looking gear to none other than
my main operator ella and those sticky
bombs now with some
react special abilities with the really
exciting
analysis containment team logo
of course you gotta get the air job
ready and then the epic
three-person walking stance you know the
hero scene
i know such a strut but i know
the asmr in the scene is uh probably
great for some horrible for me it gives
you that immediate cringe sound you
could just
tell by hearing it and seeing it that
this is just something you don't want on
you and this is the asmr that i put on
to go to sleep too
no kurt please
first thing when we enter this we have
see we've seen nests where habana is
being
captured in that really sweet ace margu
that persia loves so much
uh but furthermore like coming from her
is the sprawl which is like
starting you can see he's like starting
to cover up the entire side of this
uh this tenderloin music venue which
we do know is the thing where that
will spread over time um so that's
i'm curious like if by the time when
they first enter this what it'll look
like by the
end of an extraction
but something that i really love
actually about
this whole trailer is that you get a
huge sense of teamwork
you get a huge sense of collaboration
working
with your teammates and they talk about
it right here in the chopper they're
setting up
you know take out the nests find habana
also we need to find an exit so we're
thinking much just about going in
as we are getting out and everything in
between but it really all comes down to
the teamwork of the three for them to
get through it which
i think is obviously great for
cinematics here but i think it's heavily
implying that
this is not going to be your typical pve
where you're just running and gunning
you're going to need to strategize with
your team and you're going to need to
coordinate appropriately
there seems to be a few extra layers of
having to get in and
out uh which is something
really exciting to kind of messing with
my already my siege dna of how i kind of
extract things and deal with certain
situations so that's really really
really exciting and there's only three
of us
so we got the three coming in all
different directions being tactical and
then we got
these dudes shooting spikes from their
arms
an alien threat that we know nothing
about has landed on earth and now
they're firing these questionable
projectiles at us they're piercing
through
you know very thick wooden tables
piercing through bricks this is
terrifying they got some skills
yeah but look how fearless ella is
that's because
she's the best we know this already
but what i love is that we still get
that
rainbow six essence we're still throwing
down our tacticals
these are still the operators we know
and love but now we're seeing them in a
different
element which is pretty cool because
we're getting to see
their unique traits shine in a different
light
and we're seeing different synergies
between these three characters
and then we got this dude backpack nest
mcflying creature out of nowhere
creature
he's terrifying look at him i already
got the spikes out there
we got nomad with the the clutch shot
with the air jab
for certain enemies like that it's when
you see a character like no man who
launches it and starts firing away
like we're gonna have to communicate as
a team to make sure we're not around
when the thing actually explodes
definitely looks like it's got a pretty
wide radius definitely gotta be careful
oh look at the goo on the floor growing
and it's moving fast what is that that's
really concerning
all right we got the react drones now
looking
like they're prepared to roll through
some goo look at those tires
and you bring up a good point like i
wonder how that's going to deal with the
sprawl that goes
so quickly on how like uh and how
you're going to be able to identify when
is a good time to like roll the drone
out to be able to try and survey the
area that way
when you're gonna be standing in a
specific place that's
terrifying no i am team
it's on the floor it's on the walls it's
on the ceiling
and the tormentors can just rise up
out of it whenever they want it really
makes me think
i need to watch out where this stuff is
more than
you would normally because they could
just pop out of anywhere
you're really starting to see unique
differences between
all of these enemies and even more
things for us to be aware of when we're
trying to fight in and out of this place
you can actually lose access to an
operator if you go down on a certain
mission they go mia
and in order to get your operator back
and be able to place them again we have
to be able to go in and extract them
and actually may be a really good way to
get around the sprawl when a sprawl is
like
instead of having other players
barricade areas we're probably now going
to have sprawl taking over certain entry
points
on top of that it's really not going to
be the same when you play through it
again you know the environment itself
is going to be different too so the
replayability on these mods are going to
be
fantastic and finding new and better
ways to either get it done faster
or more efficiently is going to be a fun
way to go about it too
all right this claymore is huge this is
what lets me know that react has some
very special tech because this claymore
is not your average claymore
this thing is shooting some major
voltage
i just want us to look at them like
coming
into the world and then just immediately
getting tased
it's like when you grow up and they're
like oh here's adulthood
we've rescued hibana one of the people
in the crew has to carry the operator
back
that's a very stressful thing you just
pointed out
because that's what makes this whole
final fight right here
play out the way that it does because
lion can't really get the shot off
on the breacher knowing that when this
big bad dude shows up that things get
even more heightened and even
more stressful woof just when we think
we are going to make it out of here
alive and just when we thought we saw
enough monsters
no brand new head honcho ugly as hell
pops out start screaming at us and is
controlling
all of the goons in the whole place i
really want to shove like
a grenade like perfectly into that hole
like i feel like that's like
me like that's like a puzzle piece where
i just get to like take like a grenade
and just set it right in there and be
like
sayonara dude we see a little bit of
wombo combo
action out of nomad and out of ella with
the air jab
and the fragger knee perfectly timed you
know the the
synchronization is on point but ending
it off with that
friendly fire chef's kiss
we're seeing a lot of pretty hair and a
lot of chiseled mugs
but one of them i think that's lion he
must be getting soft in his old age
he's taking his mask off for his first
team
that's lying we don't get to see him
much that's awesome i mean i feel like
it's reiterating that family aspect
right
sometimes when you're around family when
you're around you know
the people you love yeah exactly you put
you you get some layers off you make
yourself at home i'm
my italian grandmother out of nowhere
lion take that mask off have a handful
of meatballs
the real question is when is the lion
cosplay coming from kurt because
just tilt your head in that same angle i
think i think
i think it works boom
spot on right there there you have it
everyone
that is rainbow six extraction and it is
gonna be available on september 16th but
you can go ahead and pre-order that bad
boy right now just about
everywhere and in the meantime if you
want even more information then
obviously stay tuned to gamespot but you
can also follow extraction
at r6 extraction so lots of information
on the way thank you guys so much for
watching and of course
we will see you next time